it's pretty crazy that it seems like
many of these people are getting their
news from television or from Twitter but
it's human nature at this point right a
lot of this content that gets shared
around that's where people are learning
from walk us through what is the
difference between the
hydroxychloroquine I think it's how you
say it
and there's it throw Meissen what are
those two things kind of at the core
right and understanding that most of the
audience isn't gonna be highly
scientific but just how would you just
share out those so hydroxychloroquine is
really used mainly as an
immunosuppressant so it's actually uses
for treatment in patients with
rheumatoid arthritis or lupus kind of
suppresses the immune system in a way to
keep the body from attacking itself it
also again has antiviral properties and
anti-parasitic properties so it's used
as a prophylactic or treatment for
malaria it's very popular in in Africa
the therm Ison is typically known as
being an antibiotic usually prescribed
for bacterial infections but studies
have shown that has antiviral properties
so corner virus is a virus it's not a
bacteria so that's a very important
difference that's why they can't give
you antibiotics for just a seasonal cold
I mean you could ask them people often
ask for them but it really isn't gonna
actually help cause it's a totally
different type species but as if they're
mice it actually has antiviral
properties in bronchial epithelial cells
and this is where corona virus will
attach and in fact is a lot of the
respiratory tract and so as they throw
mice and it makes sense why it could
help treat or be preventative treated
for your inner foreign invaders got it
and then when you talk about those being
used in unison is this actually like a
scientific mixture right meaning that
you're creating one single solution by
combining these two or is this two
separate either shots or however they're
actually administered they're kept
separate but you basically take them at
the same time correct so in the French
study which is really the most data we
have at this time on this combination
therapy it's two separate
so you take your hydroxychloroquine and
then you take his at the Meissen and so
what he did for the hydroxy cork when it
was a 10-day treatment of it at 600
milligrams a day and then as a therm
Ison was a 500 milligram loading dose
the first day and then 250 milligrams
for I believe the next four days so oral
form separate pills but used in tandem
combination got it and so where do we go
from here right we've identified these
two drugs that we think have the
potential to be effective in treating
this we've got what I'll call kind of an
initial early study that shows some
encouraging results we obviously don't
have time to go through kind of the
traditional process but as you mentioned
earlier we want to make sure people are
safe and actually can validate the
efficacy of this so like what does that
process look like or where do we go from
here
so I think one of the what I kind of
alluded to earlier one of the
interesting things about
hydroxychloroquine is so many people are
already on it so you already have a
million or so people so if there is a
way to analyze that data that already
exists and see if any of those people
are getting infected with coronavirus
and as the incidence or prevalence of
coronavirus goes up you should start to
see overlap you should start to see
lupus patients or rheumatoid arthritis
patients who are on hydroxy Bookman as
becoming infected and so if you were
able to create a study that could
analyze that group of people and maybe
it's to self-reported or some other
means then I mean I think a safe way to
evaluate efficacy of this drug very
quickly as opposed to doing a controlled
trial where you're a placebo and all
that